it's been like a reckoning i'm not gonna
lie
it's been like a reckoning and and i
wrote about it in my
in my last book i had to because how
you're mothered and by the way whoever
you identify as that person in your life
whoever is that person
who has that role in your life um
affects you like how could it not
whether if you have a relationship
or a lack of not having that
relationship
can impinge just as much as having the
relationship
so it's been really really crazy i'm not
i'm not gonna lie having to look at that
has been really really hard and that's
why i felt i
i needed to write about it to like
comprehend it for myself
yeah and i think that they're the aspect
too of just
sharing and um you know
planting seeds with other people of like
hmm
wait that pattern keeps showing up maybe
like i mean i spent a lot of my life
thinking it was never my fault right
like and then you end up realizing that
it's your perception on the situation
it's your patterning it's your
you know the the kind of relationships
or dynamics that you attract to
show you your healing because like you
need that other per other person or
other child
a child or something to reflect
something back to you
and it's such a journey i mean to to
unpack the
the childhood programming is is really
deep deep deep work
i mean i've had i mean i've i've had
therapists i've for a while had two
therapists
and you know there's a there's a lot of
reflecting that needs to happen to get
to the bottom of it and i don't know
about you but all of my
sort of reckoning um as you said
or breakdowns to breakthroughs felt like
i mean they felt nuclear like i would be
like sobbing like uncontrollably going
what is it where is this coming from
right right and then you come out the
other side and
you know there's so much lightness to it
and i always tell people that are
if once you've started to once you
started to like dive into
childhood trauma or patterning
like you're so much of the way there
already because most people never do
yeah but you know it's so funny with
what you're talking about where it's
like
i'll have periods of time where i'm like
still
like i'm still talking about my
relationship with my mom like
even now it still affects me this deeply
yeah isn't that crazy and it's like but
it's true
you know what i mean it's um it's so
deep in there and we're just like trying
to get to it and figure it out but i i
really do have
times where i'm just like really still
like at this point in my life i'm still
like
affected by you know my whatever with my
mom but
our parents have such a huge impact on
our everything um
it's crazy it's crazy and now as a mom
i'm like whoa this is a big
it's big big responsibility you're
responsible for their
for their attachment style for their
sort of trauma orientation as they go
because you're getting they're going to
have yeah because i don't want them to
be in therapy at 40 and be like
my mom you know yeah well i i nearly
am i mean i'm like just handle that for
them please
but what um like what were the things
that you uh
that you say when like not okay what
were those things that were not okay
that you're like look moving forward
with love these things are not the
patterns that i'm going to continue with
my kids
yeah i mean you know
again now now that i look back on it
it's um
being that we did have such an
unconventional upbringing
and while that kind of um
freewheeling lifestyle i tended to do
pretty well in and i think it's
another reason why when i was 15 and
i was you know gonna move to a foreign
country and and work by myself my mom
was like okay go
would i ever let my 15 year old daughter
do that
no like i literally she dropped me off
at the airport and i had a
name this is grandson this was in 1995
so things were very different than
we didn't have cell phones when she
dropped me off the airport i had the
a scrap of paper with a man's number
written on it we didn't know who this
guy was or someone i was supposed to
call when i got to italy
and she's like all right love you and
like drives off
you know but but back then it's like
she she was always kind of this sh an
eccentric artist as well so i think just
the idea of me going and working in
italy she was like go and i think there
was a part of her that knew i'd be okay
but even still looking back like i would
never
um let my kid do that but i think
a lot of the hands-off parenting
of never talking to her kids about
anything
um that we would be going through as
children oh sure
being emotional being emotional yes
being held that way
yes and being a kid it sucks it's
like so hard it's hard enough just being
a person
and being a kid i'm gonna learn all this
stuff oh my god like
you know it's just you know now
it's like i can reflect on stuff like
okay cool so
i know that what that person's doing
i've worked with enough people in my
career to know like okay that person
stay away from that person don't work
with them you know what i mean like
as a kid you're just there's so much to
learn and it's so awful
um and and you're learning all the stuff
you're like social
peer groups and this and that whatever
and puberty and growing up and like
my kids aren't there yet but they will
be and i'm gonna talk to my kids about
all of it